[Music]
route behaves I'm so glad you're here
welcome to the Sweetwater secrets
preview show for episode three 12
chapter 47 bizarro Dale
I'm your host Liana Galera and once
again we're live now I'll be responding
to your questions and comments at the
end of the show so start writing me your
thoughts you guys are already flooding
the comments right now I see you guys
star said it says they are so excited to
hear what KJ has to say about barchi and
purple pancake says I'm so excited for
the Shoni content we've been all waiting
for oh yes lots of news for you guys
today I'll be bringing you my three
massive clues about bizarro Dale plus
I'm dishing out exclusive interviews
with Ashley Marie talking all about mrs.
Josie McCoy's mysterious love life and
then KJ epi' and Lily Reinhart are
revealing what they really think about
barchi and you won't want to miss it
but first let's jump into your hisses
kisses comments and theories that you
all left unsweet water after show for
episode three eleven chapter 46 the Red
Dahlia kicking us off Sophie Ella
commented kisses to Nana and Smithers
yes I know right I love me some mana
rose and I love me some Smithers
together I want all of it but apparently
reading k10 is not Nana Rosa's biggest
fan
they wrote why is everyone still
standing Nana rose she freaking took a
little girl into her home just so she
could have a child bride for her son
even if Penelope is now garbage she was
just a kid back then being groomed for
marriage way too early okay I hear you
reading k10 and that's a valid point but
when we saw Nana Rose army crawl to the
phone to call up Tony so that she could
free Sheryl from the sisters of quiet
house whole hellhole
she won my affections for the entire
series do you agree with me tell me in
the comments
moving into the theory section Chrissy
Howard posted I have a theory that
instead of killing chick how
wound him to be The Gargoyle King
interesting but when you consider the
fact that the gargoyle King was around
whom the parents were back in high
school I'm thinking that the math is not
quite right but is the underscore yo 3 3
3 thanks oMG what if chick is the dealer
that Hermione was talking about and
wanting to make money after Betty tried
to kill him so many theories about chick
you guys only time will tell but
speaking of the buyer real spooked wrote
I think that Edgar ever never is the
buyer and we will finally get to see the
farm yes take me to the farm now if you
told me at the beginning of season 3
that I'd eventually be begging to see
Alice's cruelty farm family I never
would have believed you but switching
over into some romance vibes you need
Karen eek said kisses to Josie for being
there for Archie and helping him sober
up also a little kiss to her calling him
red that was kind of cute yeah it was
kind of cute but Meagan Simpson she
wasn't having it she countered with I
hope Archie doesn't end up with Josie
because she needs to get with Sweet Pea
all right guys who should Josie be with
you know I said you all in last week's
live preview show that I wasn't sure
that I was feeling these are Cho's vibes
that all of you are picking up on so I
turned straight to the source and asked
my favorite diva Ashley Marie to dish
her thoughts about Josie's love life
past flirtations and what she hopes will
happen next
take a look talk about josie and sweet
pea
we got a little flash of that in the
first episode back yeah you did I really
liked him together a puzzle a surprise
date seeing it from Sweet Pea side when
you're just like kind of hard up for
somebody and you know it's definitely
unexpected and then all of a sudden you
realize very quickly that they are not
in it the same way you are it sucks you
know being in it from Josie's
perspective it was hard to hear some of
the things that he had to say but you
like it was a summer fling like you knew
that I told you what the deal was not
even at all cool drink sweet one like
you
to distract me please Josie and Reggie
have a little bit of a flirtation in
season two together
no no but like I just think that it's no
guy's good enough for her fair yes we
had seen a little bit of flirtations
what do you think Josie's gonna think
about Miss Veronica mr. Reggie getting
together honestly I don't think it's
gonna bother her that much again because
it just never got to a place where it
could be hurtful yeah so you know I
think if anything
Josie might be more concerned about what
Veronica might think Josie's sounding
incredible these days only the best at
labahn the week I'm thinking we need to
get I loved it that's six rooms Josie
are you interested in that yeah I think
it would be really nice for Josie to
have some healthy consistency mm-hmm I
think it'd be really good for her
all right babes what did you all think
I'm Ashley's answers how are we feeling
now as we head into episode 312 Josie
and sweet pea or Josie and Archie tell
me in the comments but for now let's
dive deeper into what's next with a
quick look at the promo for chapter 47
Cesaro Dale go you are gonna come up
with the money to pay back what's owed
so we all receive letters return to
school finish the game great more
teenagers
The Gargoyle King has one
shut up and listen to me
right
[Music]
so much happens in this episode and I
love it so much more than all the other
ones and so now I'm going to tell you my
three clues about this episode and you
tell me if you can crack them number one
one riverdale lien is definitely a snake
in the grass
emphasis on the snake part number two we
get our sexiest montage ever in this
episode and I know that's not really a
clue but I think that you all need to
know that it's about to get h.o.t hot
and number three a first fight will lead
to an epic declaration of love and I'm
the only person who will be bringing you
all this exclusive scoop now river babes
this is the epic exclusive that I've
been teasing to you all so let me just
tell you this if you're a fan of show me
then you do not want to miss Thursday
Sweetwater Secrets after-show trust me
you're gonna love it
now switching from one hot and have you
ship to the potential of another I asked
you river babes to vote in a poll on ETS
community tab about what you think about
Betty and Archie and more than 13,000 of
you voted now 80% of you said you think
they're better as friends while 20% of
you said they're totally endgame now I
want to make a note to all you River
babes out there especially because I can
practically hear all you bug head fans
screaming at your screens right now as
always I will support your right to ship
whoever you want on the show which is
why I will always try to get inside
scoop straight from the stars about as
many different pairings as possible I
want each ship to get their time to
shine so there are a lot of barchi fans
out there who are constantly asking me
about this comic book couple so when I
caught up with Lilly Reinhardt in Kappa
I asked them for an update on barkis
potential romantic future take a look at
what they told me Betty and Archie fans
who are still out there we have to say
about that hold tight
you might be holding on for a long time
but it'll come
do you think that Betty and Archie is
still a possibility in the future I
don't think it's not a possibility yeah
I really I don't know I think the barchi
fans are gonna take that with it I think
it would have to be specific
circumstances they have a lot of love
for each other and their friendship is
really beautiful and cute so I would
hate to have that ruined and if they
were to break up you never know I think
there is a world that they could be
together maybe not this season but you
know eventually we've got to get every
comic book iteration I feel you would
kind of have to be like back to square
one like that's a pretty bad way to put
it cuz it's like Betty would just have
to not have been with Jughead maybe
things didn't work out I don't know it's
hard to imagine the core for not as they
are right now like even with Archie and
Veronica breaking up it's like that
shifts the core for a little bit and
feels a little sad and uneasy I kind of
don't like the core for when they're
separating but luckily bug-head is still
together no rest for the wicked not no
waited town so there you have it
that is your latest barchi update for
season 3 so start telling me your
thoughts on what KJ and Lilly had to say
and now I'm gonna take a look at what
you all have been saying during our live
Q&A portion let's go right off the back
my producers are telling me that you
Shoni fans are going insane I am so
excited for you guys I'm not gonna
really reveal too much about what I'll
be bringing you in the after show but
basically it's a nice long sit-down with
Miss Vanessa Morgan and I will be
revealing something that you've never
seen before
so it's gonna be really special let's
take it back to the beginning of the
comments Victoria said better be good
bar Chiti I think that there was a good
mixture between bar chichi and bug-head
tea in there but a lot of you barchi
fans have also been asking me to spill
the scoop on them and what's coming up
for them like I mentioned earlier this
Naya this week's episode is very hot and
there is a great bug-head scene and
basically I know that you guys have all
been worried about bug-head next week's
preview show I will be bringing you new
scoop from Lilly and Cole talking all
about bug heads so don't you worry I've
got your back bug head fans but I once
again I like the fact that they are
solid this year so got exclusive quotes
for you about that get excited
let's see gummy bear pizza which I love
gummy bears and I love pizza I'm not
sure if I would want them together gummy
bear pizza says I really hope Hyrum will
back off now but it was easy for him to
say let's make a truce when he was weak
and to couldn't do anything anyway so
true it's it's so easy when he's laying
in the hospital bed and Archie had a gun
and he was like trying I don't even know
I'm tired of Hyrum I need a break I know
you guys all agree Penelope's gonna
start bugging you now but what are you
gonna do we always got to be mad at one
riverdale parent right Katherine says I
just want Fallas to get some screen time
alone in that with bug head or the other
parents Katherine human both girl I need
some phallus and also a lot of you non
phallus fans have been trying to point
out what phallus sounds like I don't
care that's their ship name and it's
established so we're sticking with it
Taylor says Shoni and our chose e are my
favorite ships
Shoni because they helped me come out as
a lesbian to my family and our chose e
because i think they have great
chemistry and josie deserves more screen
time Taylor that is so lovely to hear
I'm so glad that Sheryl and Toni's
relationship has been able to help you
and I hope that it's been able to help a
lot of other Riverdale fans out there
tonight's episode dives really deeply
into the LGBTQIA tones of it all and
there are some really big things that
happen there are some really big
declarations that are made in this
episode that I know a lot of you show me
fans have been waiting to hear
it's a very important episode I thought
it was brilliant we get a lot of kisses
from all different kinds of couples it's
probably my favorite episode of the
season if I've already said that I'm
just saying it now Aiden says I really
want for Gladys and Betty to meet and
when they do I wonder what they're gonna
think about each other I also want to
see Betty and jellybean meet I need some
more bug-head scenes so I actually spoke
with Lilly
and Gina Gershon about what Gladys and
Betty are gonna think of each other they
hadn't yet filmed a scene together so I
have their speculations you know if
diving deeper into that in a couple
episodes but they said some really fun
things I can't wait to see what happens
when they do eventually meet I would
like to think that they would have some
mutual respect for each other but who
knows marry PR says LeAnn should write
an episode of Riverdale she is so
respectful over the ship's it would be
the best first of all that is very sweet
of you I have never claimed to be a
writer I wouldn't know the first thing
about writing an episode of television
which is why I always like to say that I
have so much respect for the Riverdale
writers it must be so difficult to
balance such a large ensemble cast with
all these different tones I wouldn't
even know where to begin from it but it
would be fun I don't know one day maybe
I think I'll just keep telling me my
hisses and kisses in the meantime how
about that that works for me
Kathryn says Salus is like the favorite
parents ship but still gets nothing
on-screen do you know if we will have
anything in the future Roberto still
says their cannon interesting once again
Roberto dropping all these nuggets
without telling anybody
he's just spoiling everything and I love
it I don't know if they would be Canon I
personally loved them together but I
would like to see a bit more about
Gladys and ESPYs past I want to know
what really made their marriage fall
apart
was it circumstance was it a fight I'm
not sure but if we did have to have a
love triangle I'd be okay with seeing
that you feel free to disagree with me
Neela says peaches and cream oh so a lot
of comments about peaches and cream but
Neela says peaches and cream
so maybe Heather joined the Serpent's
and like this is her nickname I'm not
sure who Heather is or you refer to
Heather's the musical I will say that
you might be seeing peaches and cream
sooner than you think
there's that Sammy says we know we see
Gladys in the promo
will we see JB this week
mmm
Jenny pie is Kelly Ripa coming back I
don't know if Kelly Ripa's coming back
but if she does I would like that scene
between Kelly and Mark Consuelos
together because they are married and
they didn't even share a scene together
I would like that
I don't like adultery and I don't like
that Hermione and hire are now having
like massive Affairs even though hi I'm
kind of killed a person mm-hmm
things are weird man this is Riverdale
um oh and I'm getting yet another note
that my hair is going crazy so just
gonna take a second fix that thank you
very much for that um moving on to a
couple more Peter says had anyone
noticed that Veronica and Betty barely
have any scenes together anymore
Veronica only has scenes with Reggie and
Jughead but her friendship with Jughead
is actually strictly business now yes I
desperately need some B & B in my life
and so does Lilly Reinhardt so I will be
bringing you that scoop from her we
talked a lot about Betty and Veronica
this season or the lack thereof and also
what Betty would think about Veronica
and Reggie together as a new pair so
that will be coming for you guys soon
but I completely agree we have not had
nearly as much Betty and Veronica as I
want and yes it seems that the only
scenes that Veronica really shares any
mores with Reggie which is fine I will
tell you though that this week I do
finally start to ship them so that's
exciting they're really cute so I'm like
alright I'm starting to finally feel
this oh my gosh all you show new fans
are just making me so excited Coco will
our chose II happen if Ashley is going
to be on Katy keen yes you guys the news
is out there so when you originally
asked me about this a couple episodes
ago if Ashley Marie was going to be
going over to the new Riverdale spin-off
I genuinely did not know but when the
news was officially announced that miss
Josie McCoy would be moving to New York
to start and Katie Keene the new
Riverdale spin-off I was so thrilled I
immediately texted Ashley and told her
how excited I am
she's finally gonna get this time to
shine and I think it's so great what
this means for our chose II or any
relationship that Josie has I'm not
quite sure but knowing Roberto he said
that this has been the plan from the
beginning that Josie was always destined
to go to New York so we will see what
happens I'm not quite sure but I am
excited for Ashley I'm so excited that
she is gonna have this moment she
deserves it
let's see we've got a couple more that I
want to get through bringing it way back
to the beginning of it Tessa says I
think Josie and Archie may not work out
Archie's obviously still hung up on
Veronica maybe I don't know he was just
drinking at her bar I think I think
Archie's just hung up on a lot of things
Archie needs to work through some things
and this week we're finally gonna see
him get back on the right track we're
getting a lot of season one vibes which
I was personally really excited about
cuz I loved season 1 so I think we're
gonna be okay
chat jazzy Jones says Kevin better not
drink out of that cut from Griffin's and
gargoyles Kevin has a hard episode
tonight you guys and you know how much I
love my Kevin it's a hard one to watch
but good in a lot of ways but really
hard on many keeping it going Dawn of
the Dead says hisses - Alice already you
know get sister Alice this week she's
just being normal which is exciting all
right we've got some new ones coming in
right now
ooh Alicia says do we see some
background for Tony in this episode
can't wait for the show any moments well
Alicia we don't see background for Tony
but we do get to know more about her
past she reveals a really big secret in
tonight's episode and it's really gonna
tug on your heartstrings and so I was
really excited to finally peel back a
little bit more of those layers and I
know vanessa was excited too so you'll
be getting scoop from her later Venus if
Kevin gets hurt I will cry so much he's
such an innocent person Kevin I love him
so much I adore Casey caught two pieces
but like there's a special place in my
character living heart for Kevin Keller
and he just watch what we'll all hug
each other later Maya Driver
she has thoughts on our Josie she says I
don't ship our Josie Archie deserves
some time to get back to his normal self
before dating before dating we'll go
back to Ronnie I do agree that Archie
needs to be single I agree that everyone
needs to breathe a little bit but you
know if it puts him back on the right
track and if he always has to have a
girl to kind of push him to be normal
whatever you know it's Archie amber s uh
I don't want to meet peaches this is
gonna mess things up for show me why
would you say it messes things up for
show me no it's just another girl I
don't think so
lots of fans are asking if the wedding
is this season which wedding hmm which
wedding Nora says will anyone go to
therapy on Riverdale like we need
representation of therapy I mean a lot
of people could need some therapy and
you'll see after tonight's episode that
one character in particular really needs
some therapy that would that in therapy
I feel like would make a killing in
Riverdale but yes I agree on a more
serious note everyone needs to work
through their mental health issues in
their own way whether that's through
music like Josie had said last week or
through punching or something like that
I just want them to channel their
aggressions and their mental health
issues into something constructive and
positive we are gonna just take a couple
more questions right now guys because I
still have to fill in the after show for
you I'm so excited
Kolak Sabina says I think Gladys Jones
is the buyer I don't trust her she just
gives me bad vibes I'm not gonna speak
on to whether or not she is the buyer
but I will say I think that Gina Gershon
performances Gladys is amazing you
already saw in the promo where she goes
teenagers again I think that her
delivery is so great she's a really fun
way to kind of poke fun at the things
that we always talk about on the show
like the fact that like yes why our
teenager is carrying out these mobster
responsibilities so I like her I think
that she creates a nice little mirror
that we all need a lot of folks are
asking about Edgar ever never once again
mmm-hmm but farms cows crazy people
Munoz Ellen Roberts can veggie be more
open with Archie they have been open I
don't know if they're necessarily going
to start like flaunting their PDA around
Archie that would be a little
insensitive but I don't know you will
start to see some more PDA from veggie
though and then oh they think it's bug
heads wedding you guys this is the first
I'm hearing of this interesting um I
haven't heard anything about that and
once again I've said this before I'm not
a fan of like high school weddings and
like high school pregnancy storylines I
just feel like we've seen them too many
times Riverdale has enough crazy things
going on without seeing like high school
sweethearts getting married right away
but it is Riverdale it's happened before
I think FP and Gladys were high school
sweethearts and then got married really
young I don't know who knows if it does
happen like trust me I will be fighting
to catch that bouquet because I want to
be in the episode and like wearing a
bridesmaid dress I will talk to Roberto
about that if it actually happens but I
don't know how to feel about that
three more can't relate says Fred needs
a love interest Fred needs a hug if Fred
and Kevin Keller ever wanted to go off
and just go fishing together and just
have a nice like a wholesome like
completely platonic day I think that
that would be so nice they would have
such a nice time together friends were
Fred well let's bring back Molly
Ringwald I would love that
let's let's get Fred some lemons okay
Natalie says is Edgar the new high room
I have a feeling he eventually will be I
think that as the back half of season 3
progresses and we meet Edgar ever and
ever he's probably gonna be getting most
of my hisses in our hisses and kisses
but that's fine I need a break from hi
room so I'm fine to add someone else for
now and let's see one more question
[Music]
cat or Kate Kat Kait hi when do Tom and
Sierra get married if you saw in the
promo it looked like someone was in a
little white dress in this week's
episode so I'm not going to say when
they get married but I will say that if
you tune in to tomorrow's episode of
Sweetwater you will have exclusive
answers from Ashley Marie about whatever
happens in tonight's episode and her
thoughts on what may be or may not be
happening is that Meg enough for you but
are you still picking up and I'm putting
down I think so and I think we're gonna
we're gonna end it there for now thank
you river babes
so much we're tuning into today's
preview show and be sure to check back
with me from Sweetwater secrets
after-show for episode three 12 chapter
xlvii bizarro Dale because I've got that
massive exclusive that I cannot wait to
show you it's so cool it's a new piece
of something I can't tell you any more
than that but for now please give this
video a like hit subscribe and then head
on down to the comments to see if you
can crack my three clues about episode
312
plus who are you shipping Josie with and
after watching my chat with KJ and Lilly
have your thoughts on barchi changed hmm
I don't know
tell me everything River babes and I'll
see you after the episode 5
[Music]